what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today I'm going
to do a first time watching for a movie
I have had on my list for a while since
I'm out of town at the moment this video
is going up I was like what's what's
near the top of the list and it's the
Naked Gun got quite a variety of movies
going up at the moment I've never seen
it and I hear it's a fun one and I could
use a good comedy right about now so
ladies and gentlemen leave a like I know
you can do it consider your Christmas
present to him what also subscribe and
click that notification Bell to get
notified when we got a reaction up or
something else or if there's this guy if
we do others
subscribe and also full interaction
watch as long as we single with your own
copy of the Naked Gun available for
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page that's where all of our full-length
Reaction watch Longs ago along with
several shows where we do reaction
highlights and watch along to concluded
exclusively for those series already my
intro is done it's time to watch The
Naked Gun let's see if this movie is
actually as good as people have
foreign
[Music]
no longer willing to fight
[Music]
goddamn American Hero
[Music]
he aimed way too high
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
classic
I lost 23 pounds ask me how
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm Lieutenant Frank Dragon police squad
and don't ever let me catch you guys in
America
he's the goddamn Naked Gun
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is going on right now
[Music]
this is so stupid
this is the most careless police officer
in the world
thank you
[Music]
that's ridiculous
oh it's gonna be a fun time
I did hear he was in this years ago
all 40 kilos final shipment in three
days then we'll expect pain don't worry
all right you put those headphones on at
the right time
[Music]
[Laughter]
well done please throw down your guns
[Music]
Ricardo Montalban can even recognize him
in the shadows kill him
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is my kind of Comedy there he is
he's like a National Treasure I did it
for her I did everything for her
and now she's gone
and you came down here to get the hot
story didn't you Frank they're not here
for you Weird Al Yankovic is on the
plane
everywhere I look something reminds me
of her
what about nordberg I came as soon as I
heard he's alive Frank though he's on
life support doctors say he's got a 50
50 chance of living
well it's only a 10 chance of that
what
nordberg it's me Frank your buddy
oh wow now who did this to you I love
you ship oh when you're better we'll go
sailing together on a boat we'll take a
cruise just like last year
drugs hey nurse give this man some drugs
heroin heroin Frank Norberg that's a
pretty tall owner you're gonna have to
give me a couple of days
never let a doubt enter your mind
he's right Wilma but I wouldn't wait
until the last minute to fill out those
organ donor cards you're a horrible
Frank whatever scum did this that one
man on this force will rest for one
minute until he's Behind Bars now let's
grab a bite to eat yeah
hahaha
this delivery is perfect
thank you your honor protecting the
safety of the queen is a task
that gladly accepted by police dog
or no matter how silly the idea of
having a queen might be to us
a Goodwill tour is
it
didn't remove the microphone
all right
indeed it is for all the people
who will be able to share in the uh
celebration I've never
I've always queezed the sound of people
urinating
Ed and I drove down to the docks where
nordberg had been found floating face
down on the water in the case
doesn't make sense you know
good policeman from bright future
my memory ain't so great oh yeah maybe
this will refresh your memory I don't
know it's still kind of hazy how about
this yeah I remember him I used to see
him around why do you want to know I
can't tell you that well maybe this will
help
but you don't think I should yeah you
still don't think
[Laughter]
all right all righty work at Ludwig
shipping he tried to push something on
one of my boys I swear it so what are
you gonna do about it copper why should
I tell you maybe this will help is
stupid how about now all right I'm going
down to Ludwig's office I'll find out if
you're telling the truth
[Laughter]
that was great
Lieutenant the feeling is mutual
the Japanese fighting fish
a beautiful graceful elegant
yet
single-minded of purpose and deadly Hmm
this is a rare Samurai pen a gift from
Emperor Hirohito
unbreakable impervious to Everything But
Water Everything But Water I'm
investigating the attempted murder of
one of your dog Parkers
fortunately the bullets missed every
vital organ in the salt water preserved
him until he was found so they were able
to
there is no room in my organization
criminal activity a vast commercial
development built by me do you have any
idea what was out there just five years
ago yeah
you bet you do
let me get some Kleenex
has this officer what's his name uh
Norbert oh no
what have you done uh well of course uh
he hasn't been able to tell us a thing
uh so far but as soon as he regains uh
consciousness
we'll see if
he's stupid
I'll have my assistant provide you with
anything you need you've been very
cooperative
[Music]
hahaha
I've heard police Works dangerous it is
that's why I carry a big gun aren't you
afraid it might go off accidentally I
used to have that problem
and what did you do about it
I just think about baseball
I wish there was some way I could repay
you uh
how about dinner I know this little out
of the way place that serves great
Viking food
Viking food huh get to know Lieutenant
Dragon a little better find out what he
knows I have a responsibility to the
stockholders
yes I'll do my best
go on the date
it was about 4 P.M when I returned to
police
[Laughter]
pick the names of everybody here for
questioning uh
I gotta get uh
inside
he's perfect man we're testing that new
Andy graffiti wall set to react when the
spray hits the sensor
good work Ted
will you laugh boys think up next now
that you mentioned it
I've already just rented
they're not just cufflinks each one
fires a single pin sized Dart that
knocks out your victim for a few minutes
but does no permanent damage
oh no he's gonna knock out someone he
shouldn't I can't see anything use your
open eye Frank
hahaha
are you saying that nordberg is it I'm
telling you that the queen arrives here
The Day After Tomorrow the Press should
pick this up with nordberg still part of
the force could be embarrassing to the
police and the city I'm sorry Frank I'm
giving you 24 hours to clear nordberg
24 hours
that's merely not enough time who is the
most effective assassin one who doesn't
know he's an assassin
service for two please
foreign
will that be with cream and sugar sir
cream only please
that would be a great assassin I had 24
hours to come up with something that
would clear my good friend's name
oh my God I'll be with you when I finish
with Mr norber yes doctor
[Music]
had a lot of here and a couple of oh no
where's the police officers I got at
that door oh uh Lieutenant Trevin called
and sent him home I must kill nordberg
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
come on that black car
it's definitely check her mirror
signal
now pull into traffic
you got this Stephanie I know a shortcut
turn left here
there he is easy
normally you would not be going 65 down
the wrong way of a one-way Street
yikes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the attempt at nordberg's life left me
shaken and Disturbed who is this
character in the hospital
why was he trying to
why was the I love you not listed in
Ludwig's records
and if it was did he know about it and
if he didn't who did
and where the hell was I
or I just wanted a glass of Bosco and
then slip under my blankets but my
knight was just about to begin
foreign
whoa he really did that role
[Music]
he really did that flip
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
well hello there I've been hurt before
Oh I loved her but she had her music
don't recall her playing an instrument
or being able to carry a tune yet she
was on the road 300 days out of the year
No in fact I bought her a heart for
Christmas
she asked me what it was
[Laughter]
just something I ought to tell you no
what's in the past it doesn't matter
anyway
two lonely Souls who have found each
other
that's nice I want you to know it
practice safe
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh Jesus no way
[Music]
do you have 24 hours to solve the case
you're spending too much time partying
and she told me
oh no
laugh because
I'll call you tomorrow
[Laughter]
it's very so funny man
bingo
uh to pretend to be sophisticated 40
million deposited on many banks Zurich
upon proof of Queen's death
they're gonna kill the queen
[Music]
I just knocks it all over
[Music]
oh
get out of there man
get out of there
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
whoa no way
[Music]
destroying properties are some sexual
assault with a concrete
what the hell were you doing there
I don't want any more trouble like you
had last year on the South Side well
when I see five weirdos dressed in toga
stabbing a guy in the middle of the park
and full view of a hundred people I
shoot the bastards that's my policy that
was a Shakespeare in the park production
[Laughter]
actors good ones it's your honor good
ones this delivery is impeccable I can't
imagine anyone else doing this role this
is perfect I think that Vincent Ludwig's
involved in a number of criminal
activity Vincent Ludwig is a
well-respected generous kind man it's
just too bad you don't know him like I
do oh yeah and how's that
what's that supposed to mean you know
exactly what it means he wants you to
meet with the Seventh Street Stockyards
near the 53rd Street entrance oh
ah I gotta go I'll see you tomorrow
are you sure you want to have something
to eat
what was going on
that's creepy
[Music]
I'm sorry I can't hear you don't fire
the gun while you're talking
foreign
trading shots with one of Ludwig's goons
they're planning on doing it tonight at
here security
oh yeah what about this you think we
were born yesterday you didn't do
anything he's got a picture of your wife
Ethel
all right anyone else here seeing his
wife that's all right that's okay
[Laughter]
he's got like this great delivery of
perfect handle on the physical comedy
too I don't know what you're talking
about my Stockyard meaning butter wings
or don't you remember setting that up
but Mr Ludwig said you call a meeting
off believe me find me another one
no she's innocent
cops and women don't mix like eating a
spoonful of Drano sure it'll clean you
out it'll leave you hollow inside
too bad Sugar Puffs
[Music]
generously donated by Mr Vincent
Queen Elizabeth II
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's disgusting the way they Splash this
stuff all over the newspapers
what is journalism coming to
you it's just a bunch of different
positions
logbook is planning to have someone
assassinate the queen
you I don't want you to risk this for me
I'll go alone no this is going to get
you back on the force Frank we're all
right behind you
the boys in blue
Queens attend baseball games
excuse me
Judo chop Mr Palazzo
yes I'm the head Usher
will now sing our national anthem oh boy
what a disguise
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is embarrassing
[Applause]
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God we're gonna do this today
Al it's Frank
you all right let's see if they're
uniforms straight
[Applause]
you should take a large a little tighten
the crotch
all right all set
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is that Anthony Edwards
[Applause]
call it
strike
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh man he's not he's not running this
game at all is he
stop
[Music]
interesting
so many fun props in this movie
[Music]
[Applause]
I know this is hard to believe but
apparently the umpires have got foshone
in a rundown
oh
even the guy running a scoreboard up
there says he was out
in the third out
time
I must kill
the queen
I must kill
the queen
oh no
sir
now we're going to take you for a walk
it brought an Uzi
[Applause]
America
oh God that one guy I must kill the
queen
[Applause]
oh yeah that's right the cufflinks oh no
the wrong person
he saved the Queen's life it's Enrico
Palazzo
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really tossing around what the hell
is that adult I'm going to kill you
two can play at that game
[Music]
hey ort you killed him oh no he just
stunned he'll be all right in a couple
of minutes
oh no
well
[Laughter]
Rose
[Music]
these bits this game of tops
[Music]
oh no
what
I must kill Frank Travis
no no don't shoot
you don't love me then you might as well
pull that trigger because
without you
I wouldn't want to live anyway really
finally found someone I can love
good cleaner
without utensils
but don't you dance
it's an engagement ring
I would have given it to you earlier but
I wanted to wait until we were alone
Frank
I'm sorry
[Laughter]
Monday morning we want you back at
police squad there's someone else here
who wants to thank you nurberg hi you
buddy he lives I forgot about him
wonderful
whoa Prince
Wowie
foreign
I was genuinely hilarious
I don't recognize any of these
man and woman deleted from fireworks
even these credits are funny holy [ __ ]
re-recorded re-recorded it
divorce attorney
s
Matt bakes
[Laughter]
so funny
in case of tornado
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's so funny that was great I I
really enjoyed it that was so funny
let's talk about it that
was a hilarious movie
that was so funny so funny it was a
great spoof of like film Noir detective
movies seems like it's kind of making
fun of James Bond a little bit too
um but I I love this type of escalating
uh absurdist humor because it had this
what I really noticed in the bits
especially with the way Leslie Nielsen
plays this role is because yeah like
he's got that brilliant deadpan humor he
plays everything so straight
no matter how absurd the situation gets
he plays everything's so straight and
it's it's remarkable just how impeccable
the man's delivery is because the
physical bits that especially his
physical comedy is so well as so well
executed
but then it's also his dialogue his
delivery there and he doesn't rely on
like insane amounts of energy or
anything like that and I I thought that
it had this interesting mix of like that
great kind of comedic Snowball Effect
where everything just sort of builds
upon another bit another bit another bit
and even though a lot of the times the
physicality of things can be so
outlandish there seemed to be a sense of
believability with
some of the physical painful injury bits
and the response to certain things I
thought was great so we knew how to
blend both of those so well because this
this could have easily just felt like a
sketch but it still felt like a movie
you know like it didn't just feel like a
bunch of random bits and then they're
like just throw it in here just throw it
in you're just throw it in here it still
felt like an actual film which is the
kind of spoof comedies that I I sort of
Miss and I'm surprised I've never seen
it like this at a lot of times people
are very much surprised I can't believe
you haven't seen this can't believe
you've ever seen this and then seeing
how much this film clicked with me and
just knowing the kind of con like we've
done sketches here on the channel and
the kind of sketches we like to do like
to me I'm like this is the kind of
sketch comedy sort of material that I
really do uh particularly have a fancy
for because yeah all around the the way
they handled every single bit from just
even something as simple as like the
dialogue exchange which is interrogating
that guy in the pier with the when they
keep passing the money back and forth to
each other because they're making fun of
that bit when they bribe the guy's
subscribing Frank is so stupid like the
snow when he gets out of the car and he
starts shooting at the vehicle and it's
his own vehicle
it's really like is is like the
direction and the editing is is so well
done it's it's very well calculated
because this kind of Comedy we've seen
fail
um you know like around the the 2000s
like scary movie really had a a boom of
all kinds of comedy films I don't
believe like Zucker even took over I
think these guys took over for it's
gonna be a franchise with I believe I
don't know how many they've done I was a
big fan of the franchise overall Scary
Movie
um but you know you you had the
Friedberg and seltzer films which just
did not get it like they were they were
just references you know things like
Meet the Spartans and whatever like
there were sometimes like a good Joker
there to be had but this is like the
master class version of what I feel like
these spoof comedies uh ought to have
been like because they still told a real
narrative you know you still had a real
character here with Frank because as
even though the main the main goal of
the film is to make you laugh that's the
whole purpose of the movie is make you
laugh entertain your audience and that
they like they hit every every box every
every box they checked off in my opinion
they did and but you know setting it up
with a character who's going through
what I think is is a separation with his
wife his wife leaving him and you know
that film Noir quality of uh can't trust
again and opening himself up looking for
love so having that Dynamic you you get
this character with a like who's who's
stupid he's he's not he's not the
sharpest tool in the shed but he's got a
heart of gold and so that endears you to
the character and because Leslie Nielsen
seems to have like an understanding of
that that you know he could just
he's really playing the scenes versus
just playing the jokes he's really in
the scene and he really has a character
here morphed and that's what makes it
easier to latch on to this performance
and and get lost in the world and where
you have the comedy bits that feel
surprising because sometimes you could
see a joke coming but a lot of the time
I just couldn't see the joke coming and
you think nowadays like with a film from
the 80s that the jokes would feel like a
little bit more predictable like there's
there's like sometimes the physical bits
were a little bit more obvious but it
was really like the dialogue and not
even then no man I don't want to say
that because some sometimes sure it's an
80 minute comedy so someone once in a
while you're gonna be like okay this is
that like when when OJ gets pushed down
I can't believe OJ Simpson OJ gets
pushed down the stairs at the very end
and then flies off to the baseball field
like [ __ ] like that but more often than
not you know like the way they handle
the again the build the snowball effect
of what he like
does they're making fun of the bit of
what someone's broken into my home and
he like rolls forward and the way they
capture all it looks like Leslie Nielsen
really did that but he's just flipping
through his apartment
like I didn't see that bit coming and it
just got kept getting bigger and bigger
and a lot of times you might see a joke
coming but when it gets so big that
sometimes the the the the the level of
how huge it got is the part I could not
predict whatsoever so yeah and I think
um to have Ricardo Montalban also play
it very straight without him trying to
be funny helps just to make the whole
movie funnier and I think that's a great
comedic effect it's actually really apt
to have some like Weird Al Yankovic
cameo in a film like this but I think
it's really apt to have uh the the not
app I think it's really appropriate
because a lot of times in the in these
comedy movies they try to make everyone
funny but a lot of times
if you have certain characters who are
not aiming to be funny it just makes the
person who's intended to be funny that
much funnier so the jokes land that much
more because Ricardo montalbomb plays it
like a real villain and again he's
playing a real character even the Jane
character feels like she's being played
like a real like I love the way that
they actually decided to give her some
real comedic moments because I feel like
a lot of times with the the the the you
know the leading female character in a
film like this it wouldn't even really
attempt that they would just try to give
it all a Leslie man but I really felt
like they gave her you know certain
comedy bits to really work with and a
chance for her to really Excel because
she wasn't as obviously funny uh but she
definitely had some really funny moments
as well so yeah I mean
for a spoof comedy from the 80s I feel
like this holds up remarkably well
especially like with Leslie Nielsen's
performance uh I'm so impressed with
what he's done I imagine the man has to
I think I've heard this before because
all I've really seen I I must have seen
more than just airplane uh from him uh
there's got to be other things I've seen
him and but none of them are coming to
mind at the moment but but you know like
I think he might have like a background
in drama and that just works so well you
know and and
it's refreshing to get that where you
have a dramatic actor who understands
comedy so well and the way to do it is
to play it with the utmost seriousness
and he Nails it like on every corner
like I think this was a a really great
comedy and I had an absolute blast
watching it for all the reasons I
listened thought they had great musical
choices I think the way they they knew
how to edit a lot of these scenes really
goes to enhance like it's visual comedy
it doesn't just rely on the gag itself
like a lot of it has to do with the
pinpoint accuracy of knowing when to cut
and what to cut to and also how to work
your camera and of what to what roles in
the frame it was it was really well done
I thought it was an excellent excellent
film I hope the sequels are just as good
because this was a hell of a great time
I thought it was so funny and I love
spoof I like com uh cop spoof films a
lot like in modern times I really love
films like the other guys I think that
that is a really funny bit but even that
movie you can tell really has a lot of
scenes that are freaking hysterical but
rely more on improv and I never got the
sense that there was
um a lot maybe there was but I didn't
get the sense that there was improv it
seemed like it had a really calculated
screenplay on their hands and every
actor was just doing what they could
uphold it because there's a lot of prop
comedy here too and uh I thought they
were those were all used to Great bits
as well so yeah every everything all
around was was funny there's a lot of
unexpected jokes and a lot of hilarious
moments and Leslie Nielsen was excellent
so yeah I'm glad I watched this film
thank you guys for being here with me
thank you for all who recommended this
my way because
this was an absolute Delight I had a I
had a ball of a Time thank you guys
Dan B Sure almost ended the video be
sure to subscribe and leave a like and
all those things that you're supposed to
say at the end of one of these YouTube
videos
[Music]